i i i would say oh it's again it's queen
bee i'd rather
read the source material yeah um it's a
shame because i think like it would have
been
[ __ ] amazing had a good animation
like it would have been oh yeah
absolutely it would have been like
amazing yeah yeah it was as as with
every queen bee oh no not all some queen
bees want them like this is animated
[ __ ] and the story [ __ ]
sometimes and maybe but like i said they
have like the best
they have the best steals and they have
the best covers and it [ __ ] sucks
that queen bee stop animating the best
source material queen bee
please please every time when you see a
new queen bee hentai i'm just like oh
this is don't listen to this guy i want
good animation in my hands
i want we want high quality i won my
hentai sakura
okay i prefer quantity over quality with
it you know
no i don't because you're the problem no
i'm not the problem
i am actually you are in your eyes if
that's a problem it's a good thing for
me
we need more hentai so what i'm
proposing is lower the budget
make more no no yes no no this is what
this is exactly what happened to the
anime industry
they were like oh [ __ ] i wish they
swapped yeah it's like [ __ ] quality give
me more
quantity and then look what happened
yeah i want this with but with hentai i
want the you know where you see the
seasonal schedule
for anime and hentai i want them swapped
no no
yes are you crazy yes i don't need
[ __ ] choices my penis can only get so
wrecked i don't need [ __ ] choice
fatigue with my hentai man
like there's there's already enough
hentais that is i don't want to be like
i don't need the same problem with
hentai's deal with like [ __ ] flicking
through my netflix cafe exactly you know
what i mean
i just [ __ ] watch everything anyway
let's be real i'm gonna watch everything
anyway but yeah i'm going to watch
the less the better in my opinion you
know the only time i blatantly skip it
is when i see like only lollies on the
cover
right enough of that yeah stop that no
no i get that
if you see the cover and it's something
you immediately know you're not going to
like right but here's the thing right
if if there's more quantity right then
that just means there's going to be more
wally hentai as well
well i mean i'm more more [ __ ] for me to
block yeah exactly so like why would you
so why would you struggle through that
when you could just
you know you you pick the ones that are
just all right